aquí tenemos un rectángulo dividido en
dos regiones y lo que quiero que hagamos
es calcular el área de este rectángulo
te recomiendo que detengas el vídeo y lo
intentes por ti mismo pero hazlo de dos
formas distintas
primero calcula el área multiplicando la
altura por el largo total y luego
calcula el área sumando las áreas de
estas dos regiones sale bueno vamos a
hacerlo aquí entonces una de las formas
de calcular el área de este rectángulo
es tomar este 9 que es la altura este 9
de acá vamos a ponerle 9 y multiplicarlo
por la longitud o por el ancho de este
rectángulo que sería 8 más 12 déjame
escribirle por acá 88 más 12 más 12 muy
bien entonces esta sería una de las
formas de encontrar el área pero otra
forma perfectamente válida sería
encontrar el área de cada uno de estos
dos rectángulos y juntarlas vale
entonces vamos primero con este
rectángulo de acá el área de este
rectángulo en rosa serían
sería 9 multiplicado x 8 por 8
y el área de este rectángulo de acá
sería 9 porque la altura sigue siendo 9
aquí seguimos teniendo 9 entonces sería
9 x 12 x 12 ok entonces como decimos lo
de la equivalencia de áreas pues para
empezar como juntamos estas dos áreas
como juntamos esta con esta pues la
sumamos verdad el área total es la suma
de las áreas entonces aquí le voy a
poner la suma y por lo tanto el área
total del rectángulo que es lo de la
izquierda es igual es igual a la suma de
estas dos áreas son expresiones
equivalentes porque está admitiendo
exactamente la misma región sale pero
esto está padrísimo porque si te das
cuenta lo que acabamos de demostrar o lo
que acabamos de verificar
geométricamente es que se satisface la
propiedad distributiva si tenemos un
número x la suma de otros dos eso es
igual a sumar el número por el primero y
el número por el segundo vale
multiplicar éste con este y luego éste
con éste
y aquí lo hicimos para 9 8 y 12 pero en
realidad pudimos haber puesto
cualesquiera números en estos lados de
acá sale entonces eso es algo súper
bonito que sale de esta interpretación
de áreas bueno ya nada más para no
quedarnos con la duda vamos a calcular
así ya con el numerito cuánto queda el
área de esta región entonces de este
lado serían 9 9 x 8 12 8 12 es 20
entonces serían 9 x 20 y 9 x 20 es 180
tendríamos 180 unidades cuadradas si
estas son unidades unidades unidades
entonces el área son unidades cuadradas
vale déjame borrar eso para que no se
vea feo y del otro lado tenemos 9 x 8
que es 72
72 y a eso estamos sumando 9 por 12
cuánto es 9 por 12 a ver 9 por 12 9 10
por 12 10 por 12 es 120 y si a eso le
restamos 12 que da 108 entonces 9 por 12
es igual a 108 el área desde la
izquierda 72 el de la derecha 108 y
conjuntamente tienen área 72 más 108 que
vuelve a ser vuelve a ser igual a ciento
180 que era exactamente lo que
esperábamos porque simplemente es
encontrar el área de este rectángulo de
dos formas distintas